Well, let's see. Let's try mg.
If we replace F with mg, then we get mg = ma.
Well, that's easy. The m's just cancel.
The mass of the object, it turns out, doesn't matter at all.
Isn't that a beautiful cancellation?
Disproving Aristotle with a simple mathematical cancellation.
g = a, which is exactly what we wanted to find, so this force must be equal to m  g.
We give this force the subscript g to remind us that the cause of this downward force
is gravity, and the acceleration due to gravity is this 10 m/s².
We can see that no matter what your mass is,
and we can see that regardless of your mass,
the mass cancels out.
Acceleration on earth will always be equal to g--pretty amazing.